[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren es
ist viertel nach acht herzlich
willkommen zu viertel nach acht wir
reden heute abend über den teuer schock
wir diskutieren über die immer ihren
aktionen von klimaaktivisten und wir
wollen die frage diskutieren leben wir
in deutschland eigentlich zu dekadent
ich habe dafür spannende gäste hier im
studio die buletten seiner mutter die
schufen in ihm und er weckt in ihm die
lust zu kochen erst heute sternekoch
erst heute tv star seine these heute die
gastwirte sind am ende herzlich
willkommen christian lohse milliarden
dollar genannt der brh exit und donald
trump die präsidentschaft von dort fand
die waren so der erweckung sru für die
kolleginnen und den gast nicht jetzt
vorstellen möchte sie gründete die
europapartei volt in deutschland und
findet dass es nicht nur eine neue
europäische außenpolitik sondern auch
ein europäische klimapolitik geben muss
ihre these dass neun euro ticket bringt
gar nichts herzlich willkommen valerie
sternberg er war nie
erlebte fünf jahre ohne geld wurde
unternehmer und jetzt will er
lebensmittel retten seine these heute
wir stehen vor einer hungerkrise
herzlich willkommen raphael filme und er
ist ein urgestein des deutschen
journalismus er ist autor kolumnist und
medienunternehmer seine these die
klimapolitik zerstört unseren wohlstand
herzlich willkommen georg gaffron das
ist die runde mit der wir heute und in
der wir heute spannend diskutieren
wollen mein name ist jan schäfer und wir
stehen vor einem langen wochenende meine
damen und herren viele von ihnen waren
wahrscheinlich heute einkaufen haben es
einmal mehr erlebt vieles vieles ist
richtig teuer geworden obst im schnitt 9
prozent teurer gemüse elf prozent teurer
fleisch und wurst 18 prozent teurer und
die große frage die sich stellt wenn für
uns das einkaufen schon teuer geworden
ist was ist eigentlich mit den köchen
was ist eigentlich mit den gastwirten
christian lohse der teuer schock für uns
bürger ist er gleichzeitig gleichzeitig
auch der gäste killer für die gastwirte
für die gastronomie
ja dieser tage das weiß ich nicht so
ganz genau wir haben ja immer eine
spezielle klientel
aber wir hatten das große glück dass 0
bis urne allem restaurants sitzen hatten
denn wir hatten auch ein mittagsangebot
für relativ kleines geld 18 euro eingang
aber werden auch mit 540 euro pro kopf
umsatz die ich als der höchstpreisen
restaurants europas man muss also ein
restaurant sollte populär sein und nach
oben nicht limitiert seien auch im preis
also der staat ist in willich involviert
einkaufen können was jetzt natürlich
passiert ist ich sage es mal so wir sind
daran gewöhnt den letzten jahren dass
die preise sehr weit unten waren wir
haben zehn prozent des einkommens
ausgegeben für essen und trinken dann
kam kur wird ich weiß noch ein
riesensprung jetzt haben uns daran
gewöhnt dass uns essen geliefert wird
das kostet auch geld durch die
transportwege boxen wurden gemacht da
hängen ganz viele dinge dran aber das
erste mal das ich erlebt habe in meiner
zeit also als ich koch lehrling wurde
vor 37 jahren hat man in familien gesagt
du hast immer zu essen wirst immer zu
trinken und das thema zimmer das stellte
der patron zur verfügung jetzt war es
erstmal ohne arbeit also in restaurants
waren geschlossen und wir konnten keine
berlin wäre natürlich die möglichkeit
dass wir liefern wollen aber ich habe
mich dagegen entschieden denn es gibt ja
nicht nur fünf ist es gibt ja auch
andere ist auf dieser welt und als ich
die ersten paar kartons versteckt hatte
und ich habe sehr besonnen karton
aufgemacht da sag ich nur müll drin
verpackungsmaterial und so weiter und so
fort also sie sagen wir geben zu wenig
fürs essen aus georg a front ist das so
naja ich bin etwas interessen
mehreren also erst mal ein kompliment an
sie sind einer der ganz wenigen
verbliebenen ihre zunft die das leben
genießen und anderen menschen freude
bereiten danke sehr dann das essen ist
eine ur sinnliche erfahrung die uns
manchmal selbst selbst uns in den
traurigen gedanken auffrischen kann ich
freue mich jeden tag auf das was ich es
ist ein geschenk gottes was unten sie
haben und in sofia und kohle blutig und
dazu wunderschöne pilze und an vor nach
noch was ja also krabbeln oder schwänze
dann ergänzt durch ein wunderschönes
auto und wir wollen ja auf nun geht man
herz ja auch sehen sie wir das sehen wir
uns was ich nicht verstehe ist ihre
yamaha
denn sie sind ein segment da ist die
richterskala nach oben offen ich muss
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen so haben sie
nicht verkehren kostet vorspeise und 30
schuldig der frosch im hals 36 euro die
der sag mal der steinbutt von dem sie
gesprochen haben baby steinbutt sofort
auf spinat mit einem haufen treffen 78
euro dazu natürlich einen wunderschönen
wein ein
komposch alemannia oder eine montage
nicht aus der spitzenklasse sind nur
noch gar nicht in dem bus angekommen die
dann zum motto konserviert werden ihre
kundschaft da könnten sie verdoppeln und
verdreifachen
die begebenen geht jeden preis mit warum
sie will unter sich sein den ist ihr
eigenes image verlosen sie können kochen
halten was ihm allerdings meine mama
danke lassen wollen und ich nicht
erklären das ist dieses neue kleider ich
geht das besser als wie viele gespräche
der sache gar nicht also den stein wird
auch 420 euro verkauft wird die
vorspeise für 90 euro das problem ist
nur wenn die wespe ausgeschlossen sind
daher wäre natürlich etwas ganz
besonders für eine reihe warten so hab
ich will keine räuber vorläufig
überspitzen gaststätte kochs der tv-star
aber die frage ist ja auch von unseren
zuschauern kann sich eigentlich einem
menü bei christian lohse leisten das
sind jetzt nicht so viele und ich glaube
das problem was sie ansprechen ist ja
eines was nicht nur für die
spitzengastronomie gilt sondern das gilt
ja auch für die gastronomie in der
breite her firma wann waren sie das
letzte mal im restaurant essen
letzte woche letzte woche das was was
gab es bei ihnen also war das auch
spitzengastronomie oder war dass er eine
currywurst
also weltweit 75 prozent der genutzten
landwirtschaftlichen fläche für die
tiere beansprucht das heißt zwei drittel
von allen wo wir was an bauen da wird
entweder tierfutter oder weideflächen
für die tiere genutzt das funktioniert
nicht mit fast acht milliarden menschen
das heißt ich ernähre mich seit zehn
jahren vegan also rein pflanzlich und
veganen restaurant und da gab es ja
gemüse reis und eine leckere soße dazu
ist das die zukunft so wie sie jetzt
essen weil sie auch gerade von den acht
milliarden menschen sprachen die er
ernährt werden müssen müssen wir uns
darauf einstellen fleischlos künftig zu
essen gibt es das schnitzel bald nicht
mehr also im moment ist es so dass wenn
durchschnitts konsum in deutschland pro
kopf von 60 bisschen mehr noch kilo an
fleisch haben das funktioniert nicht
wenn wir acht milliarden menschen zu
ernähren wollen das heißt wir haben
heute schon probleme auf unserer erde
wenn wir alle so leben würden wie wir
hier in diesem raum dann bräuchten wir
mindestens drei weitere planeten die
gibt es aber nicht es gibt kein backup
planeten in unserem universum wo wir
einfach irgendwie hingehen können das
heißt die ernährung ist ein ganz
zentraler baustein um unseren
ökologischen fußabdruck zu reduzieren
wir sitzen gerade auf ungefähr elf
tonnen an treibhausgasen die wird pro
jahr ausstoßen wenn wir das pariser
klimaabkommen ernst nehmen und sagen das
ziel 15 grad gemietet der erderwärmung
wollen wir halbwegs erreichen dazu
müssen die chance darauf bewahren dann
müssten wir auf 2,5 tonnen reduzieren
essen sie noch fleisch frauen stärke war
nichtig erste gelegentlich nach fleisch
sie essen auch fleisch riesiges richtig
m haben sie aber sind sie sonst auch
jemand der vegan mal kocht oder sonst
wer auf vegetarische ernährung wert
liegt wie machen sie das sehr gerne
sogar also ich bin da super offen und
finde vor allem aber und deswegen finde
ich das auch eine spannende sache
sozusagen dass wir das hier schon so
breit diskutieren
was ich super wichtig finde ist dass man
selbstbewusst oder sich der sache
bewusst was es für konsequenzen hat und
ich glaube es ging hier in
unterschiedliche richtungen zum einen
geht es irgendwie darum okay was kann
ich für eine verantwortung in der
gesellschaft übernehmen in der die
klimakrise eben kurz bevor steht und was
kann ich dazu beitragen und ich
persönlich bin der auffassung dass es in
ordnung ist ab und zu ein stück fleisch
zu essen ich bin aber auch der
auffassung dass man das sehr bewusst tun
sollte und sich eben bewusst machen
solche woher zum beispiel das fleisch
kommt aus welcher tierhaltung etc leise
gesprochen christian lohse hat ja auch
gesagt es ist so viel dass so viel
teurer geworden die korona panne
beim thema
eine frage der höhe keine in diese aber
bei der frage sind preise ist denn dann
zum beispiel fleisch noch zu billig aus
ihrer sicht also ich glaube
ja die discount fleischabteilung
bestimmt ich glaube dass wenn der preis
steigt und das ist sicherlich auch ein
guter anreiz um das so zu sehen dass man
sagt okay vielleicht gibt es einfach
auch vielleicht macht gemüse genauso
viel spaß und ich kann es irgendwie auch
irgendwie so zubereiten das ist dass es
mir schmeckt ich glaube aber auch dass
zum beispiel wenn jetzt über
verbraucherpreise wenig ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob
es jetzt wirklich die gastronomen
deswegen besonders hart trifft aber wenn
wir über verbraucher weise zu sprechen
dann geht es natürlich auch darum dass
wir uns sozusagen die ursachen anschauen
und das ist natürlich zum einen unsere
sanktionen im ukraine krieg und zum
anderen
ja sozusagen das dass bestimmte nahrungs
oder
ist richtiges kombi haben das problem
getreide beispielsweise wir sehen beim
thema milch eine sehr extreme
verknappung beziehungsweise stärkeren
nachfrage genau aber was mich an ihrer
argumentation stört an der ganzen
bewegung welcher selbstverständlichkeit
sie sagen es wird in deutschland zu viel
billiges fleisch konsumiert sie gehören
unter garantie zu einer einkommensgruppe
die in gehobenen
gastronomie und auch in der gehobenen
verkaufsstätten geben butter lindner
solche läden ja und andere sie gehören
gehören nicht zu denen die im monat
netto haben zwischen 2.000 und 3.500 das
sind leider 80 prozent dem würde ich
meinen teil widersprechen gerade weil
sie hatte ihren filmen nein das habe ich
auch nicht gesagt stell mir sozusagen
gerade nutzen butter lindner zu gehen
aber ich bin zum beispiel meine ich
koche wahnsinnig gerne selber ja aber
und wenn nicht dann bis zum
gehtnichtmehr
sie sollen sich weit die
millionenförderung das sonst nicht das
was sie hier vertreten ja das kann ich
einfach nicht leisten können das ist
eben diese erziehungs elite der
vermeintlichen die sie sich stimmten zu
sein also das problem ist doch lassen
wir hier eigentlich leisten können dass
wir noch der erde und alle so leben die
wir heute oder problem räumen davon
jedem menschen morgen eine karte in den
briefkasten zu stecken was zu essen hat
am besten ist das einfach nicht gut
drauf ist
es geht um dort seine freie entscheidung
heraus weil wir uns dessen bewusst sind
was unsere ernährung aussieht dürften
sich besser zu sein als andere weil sie
keine schwere türen hatte für mich kommt
es vor allem darauf an dass genau nichts
der staat eben vorschreibt was sollte
ich essen und was nicht aber was ich
gerne möchte es das durch aktive
aufklärungskampagnen informationen und
bildung an die bürgerinnen und bürger
gegeben werden was man vielleicht selber
als bürgerinnen und bürger auch in der
hand hat um zum beispiel der klimakrise
entgegen ziffer für sinnlose offen so
wie sie vegetarisch vater ihnen müssen
mental schwer wiegt er berühmt für
vegetarische gerichte auch sehr berühmt
ich habe eine serie von 35 verschiedenen
soßen bis auf eine so sind alle vegan
aber nicht aus dem prinzip heraus wenn
sie obst und gemüse verarbeiten dann
erschließt sich eigentlich ganz alleine
dass sie halt faktisch vegan oder
vegetarisch sind ich finde das problem
was ihr bei vegan haben das war schon
immer so die vegane fraktion oder so
also politisch darzustellen hat es
versäumt erstes mal gute lieder zu haben
und zweitens eine eigene sprachführung
zu haben und drittens haben sie das nie
geschafft eine ausgewogene ernährung hat
sich darzustellen sie müssen also da
aber was wir ein größeres problem noch
das hat er gerade angesprochen man hat
den eindruck wenn man nicht vegan lebt
dass man eigentlich ein mensch
mittlerweile zehn häufigsten es gibt
veganer ist dass er charmant wie sieht
das neue eingestellt haben das gesagt
hat im kopf
unten liegt sie heimlich eine stückweise
haben alle was davon haben wir einmal
das sozusagen stringent nach vorne
bringen herr vellmar redet sie reden
viel mehr aber dass sich das sehr
charmante london hat die gemeinde noch
singen ist der eindruck das ist diesen
moralischen zeigefinger gibt also
erstmal gibt es diese moralischen
zeigefinger habe ich sie etwas ganz
anderes kommt werden wir waren in den
letzten halben jahr auf zwei großen
messen der just die russen food messe
der welt und wir haben künstliche
nahrung gesehen ich habe mir vorbei wird
so holzspänen der geest eine brühe
drüber ich habe die inhaltsstoffe
gesehen also eine liste von ungefähr 100
zutaten stoffen das wie tomaten die auf
mineralstoffen wachsen und keine tomaten
und dann nimmt er nach fünf minuten
decke runter und nennt das dann veganes
pulled pork
das ist das dass sich die neue zukunft
seit wir glaube ich essen werden es
werden nicht die gemüse sein es wird
durch das fleisch willig der fisch sein
damit werden wir versuchen die welt zu
ernähren was da rauskommt kann ihn jetzt
schon sagen durch die fähre
mangelernährung gerade von kindern die
wir haben internet zu schlagen er hat
die hände überm kopf zusammen indem sie
sagen sechs jahre kommt zu uns weil sie
nur von sich von bergketten sowas
ernährt haben und die haben magen darm
verschlüsse und ähnlichen krankheiten
und die sind kaum zu retten also wir
müssen uns damit beschäftigen dass wir
weniger konsumieren es musste ich immer
alles zu jeder tages und nachtzeit
verfügbar sein und wir müssen uns auch
darauf konzentrieren das ist was wir auf
unserem grund auf einkommen ausgeben und
das heißt nicht dass der stein wissen
wir müssen uns also einschränken sagt
auch christian lohse raphael fame ihr
thema ist heute ebenfalls das
einschränken ihr thema sind lebensmittel
sie sind lebensmittel retter so darf ich
sie einmal bezeichnet so es glaube ich
selbst auch und sie sagen wir stehen vor
einer gewaltigen hungerkrise also wir
stehen nicht nur vor einer gewaltigen
hungerkrise wir stehen in einer sehr
großen hunger krise die es schon seit
jahrzehnten gibt wir haben fast eine
milliarde menschen die tagtäglich nicht
genügend nahrung zu sich nehmen kann
weil es an wasser fehlt an
grundnahrungsmitteln das heißt wir
befinden uns da schon das nicht so dass
wir da gerade rein schnell und es wird
noch schlimmer gerade durch die ukraine
krise ist das potenzial dass noch mehr
menschen an unterernährung sterben sind
schon millionen die pro pro jahr leider
auch dieses jahr wieder nicht überleben
werden und man muss auch dazu sagen
lebensmittelverschwendung ist ein riesen
thema was auch damit zusammenhängt dass
leute auch in anderen teilen der erde
hungern nämlich 50 prozent aller
lebensmittel die wir hier in europa
produzieren und die wir importieren
werden nicht gegessen das ist in
deutschland eine lkw-ladung pro minute
was für ein lebensmittel verschwenden
und das ist den euro ungefähr 300 euro
die wir pro person in deutschland in die
tonne schmeißen an lebensmittel und dies
gleichzeitig obwohl wir eine milliarde
menschen haben die an unterernährung
leiden und deswegen diesen globalen
zusammenhang sehen wir können es uns
ökonomisch leisten und so viel
wegzuschmeißen aber ethisch und
ökologisch ist es eine vollkatastrophe
den zehn prozent aller globalen
treibhausgase entstehen durch die
lebensmittelverschwendung
aber noch einmal ganz kurz die frage was
noch mal klar zu machen wann kommt jetzt
wie diese die hungerkrise ist volle
kanne darf volle lotte und dies in den
letzten jahren sogar noch schlimmer
geworden food waste
lebensmittelverschwendung wir haben 2,5
milliarden tonnen jedes jahr die
wegschmeißt und es steigt durch den
wohlstand in der gesellschaft in auf
fast allen kontinenten steigt die
lebensmittelfirma freunde hungerkrise
gleich lebensmittelverschwendung kann
man diese gleichung überhaupt das ist
sehr einfach gesprochen dass man diesen
block haft glock bildhaft dargestellt
man muss doch ganz einfach sehen
natürlich haben wir probleme aber ich
war dann garantiere ihnen ich denke eben
nicht in apocalypse szenarien sondern
ich sage ihnen voraus sowie habeck heute
morgen angekündigt hat die wissen dass
wahrscheinlich dass die laufzeiten für
kohlekraftwerke rung gaskraftwerke
verlängert werden dass die beschlüsse
jetzt bis 24 voraus das wird also weiter
kohle weil die normative kraft des
faktischen zwingt dieser zu wenn die
industrie kaputt geht das licht aus geht
es in die straßen von leuten voll das
kann ihnen sagen was damit passiert dann
gibt es auch in der wissenschaft weiter
ich mein gegen theesen zu ihnen ist ich
sehe einen durchbohrte gentechnik wir
werden aus einem samenkorn vier
kärnten das wird alles hier ja in
deutschland verschwiegen so sind wir
nicht richtig im fernsehen wir sind ja
ich bin ja ich bin sehr usa wir sagen
nein nicht
springen als die letzte bastion
insofern muss man sagen es gäbe würden
wir verschweigen dass sie haben nicht
nur die klugen leute es gibt so auch
noch ganz andere die in laboren sind die
arbeiten das wird einen tisch gekehrt
weil die vorstellung dieser leute ist
natürlich eine andere welt eine andere
gesellschaft und darum geht es im
wesentlichen über ihm willig 1 empfehlen
seit acht jahren sind sie vegan zehn
jahre seit zehn jahren haben sie noch
fünf jahre bis sie wahrscheinlich krank
werden ich wünsche es ihnen also ich bin
seit zwei jahren nur zweimal einer
kranken sonst durchgängige sony fünf
jahre ich habe gesagt nach 15 jahren
vegan wird bei ihm eine chronische
mangel wird auf jeden fall nehme ich
aber dass ganz wichtiger zusätzlicher
aber nicht wirklich nicht als solche
ihre diese konsens weil diese kunden zu
mögen sich zu bieten der leber
gespeichert und nach 15 jahren
speicherung vorrat so fragt wird fast so
der mediziner
die frage ist das was auch georg astrein
sagte und christian lohse gerade das ist
beispielsweise fleisch aus dem
reagenzglas gibt oder
ist das aber die lösung horror gemälde
dann werden sie nur
so viel sagen das versehen ist gestimmt
wie eine genesung leider sondern es ist
eine von verschiedenen möglichkeiten wie
jeder einzelne wie wir als gesellschaft
unseren ökologischen fußabdruck
reduzieren können damit unsere kinder
und kindeskinder auch noch sich hier auf
diesem wunderbaren bis nehmen was ich
noch jünger ist wasser in der dritten
welt ist die meisten kinder sterben an
der qualität des wassers nämlich an
cholera ich war in diesen gebieten ich
habe afrika besucht aber wie sehr gerade
im verein gesagt klimakrise ist
eigentlich unser system es ist nicht die
frage dass wasser das schlecht ist was
bringt
alles immer überstülpen klima ist jetzt
plötzlich das
sagen es gibt einen ökologischen
fußabdruck aber es gibt auch ein wasser
fußabdruck zum beispiel ein kilo fleisch
verbraucht 15 bis 20 000 liter wasser
und dieses wasser kommt nicht aus
deutsche weil die kamera steht sondern
das futter kommt aus anderen ländern
außerhalb weil ein jahr nicht genehm
auch landkarten leute unsere kühe oder
liegt ja die wir hier ein von dem
ernähren überhaupt wer sogar auf dem
boden und erwarte man klarheit
um dem namen aber das ist vielleicht
auch etwas zu bündeln es geht also am
ende um verzicht wir nein sie müssen
nicht hungern verzichten er bereits
gesprochen die frage ist verzicht also
das ist ja der punkt hunger ist was ganz
anderes nochmal ich glaub freiwillig wir
haben 30 300.000 menschen gehabt die
sich vegetarisch ernähren vor 30 jahren
mittlerweile sind es zwischen fünf und
zehn millionen menschen aber freiwillig
tun sie es und zwar verzicht kommt immer
so ich würde gerne dies tun ich würde
das gern essen aber ich kann es nicht
weil es mir nie leisten ist es für mich
verdient das ist ein deutscher spector
sehe ich ganz anders also erst mal
wieder zusammen ist und regen egal was
wir tun erst mal die erste grundregel
mülleimer ist nicht besser als die gäste
fangen mit der gleichheit war alles sehr
pragmatisch gesehen und wenn wir zum
beispiel ein schmorbraten man am sonntag
einen wärter motor dies und donnerstag
noch offen ist aber entscheidend ist das
vielleicht mit vier sechs oder acht oder
zwölf personen am tisch sitzen und wir
sozialisieren auch also ein seelen
werber das sozialisieren und dazu ist
der esstisch hervorragend gemacht wir
lehren zu streiten wir lehren zu essen
zu trinken wir lehren zu sozialisieren
und unsere mitmenschen zu respektieren
und gleichzeitiges wenn wir miteinander
sprechen und wir haben essen was
zugänglich ist was auch geduldig ist was
ich erklärt werden muss diese 50 us
turnier dieses dieser ganze quatsch dann
haben wir einen ganz schönen tag für uns
und wir gehen gestärkt von der seele vom
geist und vom körper haben mit guter
grund nahrung in die woche hinein und
ich bin der meinung wir müssen nicht
jeden morgen unsere schicken steuer
essen und ich eben daran schnitzel essen
oder drei straßen die kleine reduktion
und auch das verteilen von guten essen
tut und wenn wir dann noch sozialisieren
dazu und der esstisch wiegt ein dazu zu
sanieren auch der austausch und das
vernünftige streifen sprich zu führen
ich finde das ist eine ganz tolle sache
so erreichen sie denn ich rede von der
kultur die menschen denen kaum noch
zusammen essen kommen auf zusammen aber
es gibt erste umfrage
dass das dass menschen wegen des schocks
und in großbritannien wissen wir sind
lebensmittel dem stimmt auch deutsche
deutlich teurer als bei uns eine
mahlzeit ausfallen lassen jetzt zeigen
sie hier weiter ich zeige mal in die
heimische zeitung berlins aus dem bett
und auch in der gilt war das heute sehen
sie darauf freut sich deutschland morgen
am vatertag deutschland gilt und in das
ist aus der bz und in der bild ist nur
viel größer mit fleisch tippten die
abgebildet sind jetzt frage ich sie
wollen sie den menschen diese freude
nehmen mal drehen wenn man in deutsche
habe ich bin auch gemüse her aber die
platte ist ja und das heißt wir stehen
alle unglück herum und wie sozialisiert
wird auch wegen für die regierung selbst
dann müsste ich einen schlag
doch natürlich
unterstützen wir sie gerne fleisch
spiele wahnsinnig gerne fleisch ich war
sehr gerne gemüse dazu
ich bin da sehr sehr demokratischen
ordnung wenn herr schnitzel nicht mehr
so sind dass man sie eigentlich essen
kann schmeißen sie dann weg ich schneide
sicherlich auch mal lebensmitteln leider
weg wenn es nicht anders geht ich glaube
was was ich für mich die frage gestellt
das eigentlich wenn wir so viel abfall
produzieren wie sie es gerade gesagt
haben dann ist es eigentlich auch
volkswirtschaftlich eine ganz große
ineffizienz das heißt die frage ist wie
schaffen wir es denn abfall zu
reduzieren und dann ist das nämlich
keine moralische oder moralapostel
einstellung sondern das ist einfach nur
die effizienz unserer volkswirtschaft
die wir besser mal angehen aber glauben
sie nicht dass die verbraucher und das
ist ja immer dass wir sehen beim benzin
mittlerweile auch die deutschen fahren
weniger auto sie tanken weniger weil
benzin so teuer geworden ist glauben sie
nicht auch dass eigentlich jeder
verbraucher das schon in gewisser weise
selbst macht weil er wenn er feststellt
lebensmittel sind teurer geworden ich
schmeiße aber gleichzeitig viel zu viel
weg dass das sich am ende doch sehr auf
dem markt da möchten wir noch einmal
angreifen
ich glaube leider ist zurzeit nicht
überall die ansetzung so wenn wir zum
beispiel jetzt mal unseren unsere
elektrischen geräte nehmen ja zum
beispiel ipad dann ist es zurzeit
günstiger neues ipad zum teil zu kaufen
und gegenüber lebensmitteln also zu
reparieren das ist ja ok aber es geht
hier um abfall im allgemeinen auch erst
mal klassisch helfer bisher zu recyceln
sie noch nicht bis jetzt retten sie
lebensmittel oder wie retten wir reden
über das thema essen aber okay dann
haben wir hier also ein bürger der sich
engagiert dafür dass wir
lebensmittelabfälle irgendwie reduzieren
oder oder nochmal neu verwerten ja und
ich glaube so was kann man aber auch
eben anreize schaffen von der politik
und wie sagte schon jetzt da kenne ich
mich eben jetzt besser ausbreiten repair
also ein verbraucherrecht darauf dass
ich das recht habe etwas zu reparieren
eine kaputte waschmaschine und so weiter
und dass das dann günstiger ist als ein
neues produkt zu kaufen im abfall
lebensmittel abfallrecht ich mich nicht
aus aber sicher gibt es da auch anreize
die wahnsinnig einfach sind und die es
uns ermöglichen als deutsche nicht zu
verzichten aber trotzdem weniger abfall
zu generieren und somit vielleicht auch
einfach noch ein stück weiter zu denken
und smart zu sein und technologie auch
dafür zu nutzen da hab ich nichts aus
habe ich gesagt bekommen
ich möchte etwas dazu sagen vor 14
jahren war ich das erste mal in meiner
tante frau fuchs fleischermeister dann
aus berlin geben kadewe und dann wir
waren alleine abends zuhause ich würde
mal meine urlaub hier verbringen und hat
sie gesagt komm wir gehen es keine wege
kaufen müssen was ein und sagt wir sind
nur zu zweit verkaufen vier scheiben
brot ein und das war möglich im kadewe
konsti vier scheiben brot einkaufen wenn
ich jetzt als single haushalt also ich
habe die möglichkeit ein halbes brot
kaufen oder gleich ein ganzes brot und
was passiert entweder extrem tief gehört
dann schmeckt wenn ich mir ich muss da
ein toaster stecken also passiert es
genau das ist passiert genau das was wir
nicht wollen ich weiß dann weg warum ist
es nicht möglich dass ich mir einfach
zwei scheiben abschneiden sagt kommen
diesmal mit nach hause und es ist ja das
ist ja eben selbst belastet doch da hat
der kunde auch immer ein gewisses
druckmittel ich bin da völlig anderer
meinung ich glaube da muss der staat
kann ich glaube jeder merkt das ja und
ich höre dass auch von kolleginnen und
kollegen die einkauf und sagen mensch
ist das einkaufen teurer geworden das
ist doch da fängt man noch automatisch
an sich zu überlegen brauche ich
eigentlich ein ganzes behalten heißt ja
mindestens bist und nicht sofort tödlich
ab und welche ja nicht vergessen dass
das mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum vor 40
jahren da gab es noch gar nicht da hat
man immer auf seine sinne vertraut man
schaut sie ein produkt an man öffnet ist
man schaut man probiert vielleicht
kostet und unser gaumen schmecken
konzert joghurt den kellern der
großeltern die nach normaler der ist
nicht zwei wochen nach immer den noch
genießbar sondern greenpeace hat studien
gemacht acht monate das heißt die
meisten leute wissen gar nicht dass man
die lebensmittel viel länger genießen
kann und das wollen wir auch mit servers
mit fuß und die tafel alle diese
initiativen kümmern sich letztlich darum
des bewusstseins level in der
gesellschaft zu steigern weil wir am
ende für 50 prozent der
lebensmittelverschwendung zuhause
verantwortlich sind so ohne auf
umerziehung abzustellen und ähnliches es
sind dinge die über nacht geändert
werden konnten ich habe unlängst
diskutiert mit dem chef der berliner
tafel die nicht sehr lange kenne und der
tory chefin
wir reden wir von zwei verschieden
veranstaltung jedenfalls habe ich ist
ein geistlicher dass das desaster
gemacht hat in pankow die erste ist wie
in der suppenküche der suppenküchen und
tafeln es heute und der hat mir
berichtet dass sich aufgrund der vielen
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
das habe ich noch reste sanktionen das
war unverschämt was sie wollen gesagt
man über die sanktionen ja aber was
anderes thema nur das hat mich sehr
getroffen aber
dass sie haben die schulter sanktionen
sind auch schuld dass es in der
ernährungskrise ist in einer so viel
zeit muss sein moment bitte so es ist so
wie ich wollte ich habe viele freunde
die wie er in der hotellerie tätig sind
so das waren ja so
zum beispiel im hotel de rome oder im
interconti und ich habe gesagt ich komme
früher war ich finanziere das und wir
holen darf das jeden morgen von dem
gefäß allein
weggeschmissen wird dann sagt das darf
ich nicht aus hygienischen gründen denn
es könnte ja der korona warum einer von
den wenigen vorbeikommen und mal mussten
also also wird augenblick bitte und das
bedeutet hier wird verschwendet durch
gesetze ich habe gesagt dann müssen sie
eben tisch bedienung einführen dann wird
er sagt es ist also teuer der
gewerkschaften treiben das so nach oben
mit den entlohnung dass wir uns das
nicht leisten können das ist eine im
system immer ein handicap punkte freuen
da ist auch viel zu tun nicht nur dass
lebensmittel retten aber auch die frage
wie geht man eigentlich mit
lebensmitteln um die eigentlich jetzt
wie heißt es so schön ich sage meinen es
wird aufregend bleiben sie sitzen zu
haben dass ich sie gegessen wer über das
thema messen geredet meine damen und
herren wir reden gleich nach einer
kurzen pause weiter darüber wie
klimaaktivisten autofahrer tyrannisieren
und auch über die frage ob klimaschutz
eigentlich wirklich ohne persönlichen
verzicht geht bleiben sie dran das
gleiche
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen die damen und herren
bei 485 köpfen sind meinungen von jeder
von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht was
ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht über chip buschi hergiswil
wetten dass aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen hier einfach nur freiheit
diese grünen roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
den leuten spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dürfte sein
dass conti zum manko leicht einmal kurz
doch das sind übliche anorak träger aus
ich hatte meinen beifahrer meine sache
immer bekommt wer kümmert sich darum
niemand gibt sie ihr denn dann ist er
ganz knapp drüber sprechen das ist
einfach nicht fertig richtig durch die
ausgabe von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück zu viertel
derartiger tolle und spannende gäste
hier im studio rafa ist da christian
lohse weil er die sternberg war nie und
georg a frauen und wir haben schon heiß
diskutiert über das thema lebensmitteln
jetzt geht es um ein thema was viele
viele autofahrer umtreibt sie werden
tyrannisiert kann man fast sagen seit
wochen ja seit monaten von einer kleinen
gruppe von klimaaktivisten die sich
einfach auf die straße kleben hören sie
und schauen sie selbst
werde so nicht mehr geht aber
ich kann nicht aufstehen gerade lassen
sie mich ich kann nicht
lassen
aufstellen ich kann nicht dastehen
du kannst du jedes beben kommen werde
nicht aufstehen wenn wir weiterhin
forcieren wahnsinn jetzt weiter nach öl
bohren heute
tut nicht nur das ist nicht warum auch
noch stärker
[Musik]
hier werden
beladen
[Musik]
nicht
minute
und jetzt geht es aber kaum
georgen ist das noch klimaschutz ist das
noch kampf für den klimaschutz oder ist
das schon mehr ist da schon tyrannei
also ihr leben mit einem regelbasierten
staat das sind regeln ihres
zusammenleben organisieren
und dazu gehört dass jeder das recht zur
war nicht mehr so eine richter hat und
wenn ein autofahrer auf der straße fährt
hat er ein ziel der möchte er hinkommen
und nicht gestört werden wer nicht
unfälle und ähnliches passieren durch
dritte die meinen sie haben die moral
gepachtet und die lösung aller welt
probleme und sich auf dessen auf die
straße kleben
wissen sie sind in berlin drei notarzt
wagen mussten umkehren weil unter war
eine geburt befindliche frau sondern
herzinfarktpatienten
patientin und ein unfallopfer und da
mussten die sich durch die sozusagen
betroffenheits kultur der demonstranten
mühsam durchkämpfen um dann vielleicht
die charité zu erreichen hier hört der
spaß auf hier werden regelverstöße
gemacht im namen einer für sich
gepachteten höheren moral wenn das jeder
machen würde es gibt auch noch andere
gruppen stellen sie sich mal vor die die
alle sich da wohl fühlen und das stützen
ich stelle mir vor was ich mir vorstelle
ein fdp-politiker oder auf die politiker
die für den diesel kämpfen den verbleib
des dieses auf deutschen straßen deren
oder immer abgeschafft werden soll die
würden das genauso machen was wir dann
hier los in diesem land einmalig zu
recht ja die kommen nicht auf die idee
weil die in der regel rechts gezogen
sind und gelernt haben wie man sich
benimmt im übrigen haben die zeit ja
meist menschen die das machen ernähren
sich nämlich zum staatlichen zuwendungen
nach dem motto von der uni über die
endlos oder den öffentlichen dienst dann
gleich in den ruhestand das ist also die
eine generation die nur von zu garten
wächst die nicht zum produktiven
reformierung des volksvermögens
beitragen ich möchte aber ein anderes
beispiel sagen ich akzeptiere die
ethischen gründen sehr wohl die dahinter
stehen können nur dann muss das auch in
toleranz gepaart sein was würden sie
denn machen ich nehme an dass sie alle
für diese aktion sind frau so dem koch
aus dem meer oder vielleicht auch kann
man heute ist alles möglich also dass
wir alle sind für diese aktion ein
meinen sie das wären das also wenn sie
das fahren auf der straße und es wird
wirklich gesagt davon haben sich leute
geklebt und dann sind dass frauen die
gegen die abtreibung demonstrieren in
den usa sind dies mehrere tausend so
sternberg die frage ja überall im spiel
in fünf tage finden wir überall tagen
die deutsche ski antrieben ist steht
weiß ich ein prozess klimaschutz über
dem gesetz steht der kampf für
klimaschutz vermeintlicher kampf wie
auch immer über dem grundgesetz also
meant haben sich vorab loswerden weil
ich das mir wurde noch nie so viel
gesagt was ich wohl denke oder mein
revier schließlich so sehen sie sich in
der partei die sie anführen
weil wir demokraten sind und da darf ich
mich selber äußern und mir ich werde
nicht einfach einen neuen rücken würden
und er glaubt die zweite sache die ich
gerne richtig stellen würde apropos
rechtsverstöße der fdp ist die einzige
partei derzeit in deutschland natürlich
außer vielleicht noch weiter
rechtsextremer parteien die zur zeit vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird ja
also das kann ich nicht beurteilen aber
dass sie rechtsverstößen wir gehen ja
gerade gesagt das sei die partei die
zumindest rechtskonform erzogen wurde
oder wie sie ja nicht so hinein under
bitte das wurde über diese frau
gesprochen
nein es wurde nicht mehr klasse ist gut
dass sie das auch noch man spricht erst
mal sehr klar das hat georges tron
glaube ich nicht gesagt da ist das
türkisch ist ein falscher eindruck
entstehen so machen die das
ich glaube jetzt sind sie aber dran vor
sternberg also ich glaube der
klimawandel ist die größte
herausforderung unserer zeit und unserer
gesellschaft ich glaube nicht dass das
in irgendeiner weise rechtfertigen dass
man sich über gemeinschaft
gemeinschaftlich anerkannte gesetze und
richtlinien hinwegsetzen darf überhaupt
gar nicht herzlich willkommen im club
genau das ist ja jetzt viele frau daher
kuchen dann haben wir gar nicht mehr
ziehen würde
global betrachtet also wir sprechen
davon ja vielleicht war das sehr traurig
für die drei menschen die im
krankenwagen nicht rechtzeitig
angekommen sind im krankenhaus an den
ich geholfen werden konnte keiner sie
handlich wir haben jeden tag
zehntausende kinder die sterben weil es
nicht genügend zu essen haben da heißt
wenn man auf das thema wo sich übrigens
die un eu und deutschland committed hat
also die wollen ja das ziel ist es bis
20 30 50 prozent der lebensmittel
verschwendung zu reduzieren wenn wir
aber keine taten folgen lassen auf
irgendwelchen gremien diskutieren sie
das in kommissionen bringen sie ja
wissen ein um krakeelen nicht es muss
also dass man sich auch ich muss sagen
also es geht glaube ich am ende darum
wirklich ein konstruktiv irgendwie
vorschläge zu machen wie wir ans ziel
kommen wo fest leben ist kündigt hier
sehe ich
dass der versammlungsfreiheit zu
demonstrieren immer wieder auf ein thema
aufmerksam zu machen das hatte ich alles
für ganz wichtige legitime mittel aber
zum beispiel auch bei walt damals einem
anderen kontext dann wie gesagt das
reicht uns nicht wir wollen in die
gremien wir wollen in die parlamente
um eben wirklich etwas zu verändern was
würden sie der zeit geben sollten sie
sich fest leben erfüllen also ich habe
fünf jahre kein geld angenommen kein
geld ausgegeben genau um aufmerksamkeit
zu schaffen und was diese menschen da
geschafft haben dass nicht nur wir heute
über lebensmittelverschwendung sprechen
sondern in deutschland millionen
menschen dieses thema bewusster geworden
ist und das ist glaube ich ein adäquates
mittel stundenlanges gerade vorher firma
klebt sich fest und harry nicht
glücklich sagt klose wir haben wir haben
ganz andere sie werden ganz andere
situationen von seinem restaurant
fischers fritz dass wir ungefähr 20 noch
einmal sagen ein restaurant hier mitten
in berlin deutschland haben also dass
wir in einem restaurant mit einem lied
am sonntag gibt's kein gehör weise die
lücke es gibt einfach nicht mehr aber es
haben sich aktivisten von der firma
peter voß restaurant gestellt haben die
gäste gehen dann ins restaurant
hineinzugehen 100 meter war der monat
bezahlt werden muss ungefähr 20 wir
haben das gemacht das sind 20 riesen
ausfälle und dann die öffentliche
schädigung und dann steht und welche
leute mit witzigen masken und sie sind
der meinung dass sie mit diesen also
demonstrationen ist ein grundbaustein
unserer demokratie keine frage aber wir
müssen natürlich genau wissen in welchen
regeln was ich ihm auch gesagt haben wir
uns zu bewegen haben allerdings wenn sie
uns wirtschaftlich schädigen wenn sie
unseren ruf schädigen und vor allem wenn
sie uns schädigen und so mitarbeiter
moderne bezahlen zu können da muss ich
ganz klar sagen denen sie über grenzen
hinaus die einfach nicht machbar sind
und ich würde irgendwann raus haben beim
15 mg mit denen versucht zutaten keine
möglichkeit ich wurde sogar tätlich
angegriffen und dann will ich der
meinung demonstration hat nichts mit
ihren angriff zu tun und deswegen will
die auszumachen das fest ging auf der
straße ist nichts anders gewesen als im
restaurant sie haben uns einfach total
geschädigt und wir sind um rossi gesagt
es ging in gänze stoffe die bei uns
marginal war und es ging darum fleisch
zu verkaufen bitteschön wir sehen ja
auch beim thema letzte generation das
waren ja klima aktivisten der
organisation
die sich so nennt letzte generation
immer wieder dass es rechtsbrüche gibt
und dass das also das aber recht für
treten wird und das kann ja eigentlich
auch für klima- aktivisten nicht der weg
sein um auf sich aufmerksam zu machen
haben rechtsstaat und der muss doch
gelten kinder aber in unserem
rechtsstaat ist zum beispiel egal dass
ich einfach ein tier ermordet und es
einfach liegen lassen es ist total egal
ich kann hier schützt ich darf das
machen und wenn ich aber eine tomate aus
einer mülltonne rausnehmen ist es
diebstahl und hausfriedensbruch in
unserem rechtsstaat und so ist es und
trotzdem ist aber vielleicht global
betrachtet wieder bei machte der
weltbevölkerung deren unternehmen leidet
unser wohlstand hier und wie wir mit
lebensmitteln nämlich umgehen wenn leute
sagen die thomalla und seele also 70
kilo pro jahr wie meist jeder mensch
leute gemacht das ist halt auch aus
meiner perspektive unethisch eigentlich
auch nicht recht willkommen wir uns
einen dieser nein aber aus seiner
perspektive am ende argumentiert diese
dinge aufgreifen die 10.000 kinder
werden wohl nicht die täglich sterben an
unterernährung sterben werden mit
sicherheit nicht weniger gewesen wenn
die drei menschen die vielleicht sogar
gestorben sind ich weiß es nicht nicht
behindert wurden werden die
milchmädchenrechnungen zusammen so dass
sein schaffen nein sie schaffen ja
tatsachen entschuldigen sie dass ich das
erleben müssen die diskussion das zweite
ist mir wirklich wichtig ich habe nie
gesprochen von leuten die nicht
demonstrieren diese diese fahrer sind da
wurde ich in die nähe der afg gerückt
das ist eine unglaubliche vorgang nein
das ist dass die diffamierung
andersdenkender nach rechtsaußen dass
eine masche die durchgezogen wird sie
glauben damit durch einmal da sind kann
auf ist nicht legitim entschuldigen sie
das vergiftet die diskussionskultur in
deutschland einmal noch mal ganz kurz zu
sagen wie es möglicherweise zu einem
jahr oder sogar zwei missverständnis
gekommen ist ich habe nur gesagt wir
haben die klimaaktivisten auf der einen
seite die menschen tyrannisieren
autofahrer und auf und die frage die
gestellt wurde war ja was würde
eigentlich in diesem land los sein wenn
beispielsweise afd aktivisten oder
anhänger oder politikern von diesel für
das ähnlich machen würden um das war nur
der diebe nach den diesel zu retten er
so und sich auch feststehen würden so
das war eigentlich nur das argument um
einmal zu zeigen dass in einem
rechtsstaat und wir würden
wahrscheinlich zu recht auch bei den
fdp-anhängern wie auch immer alle sagen
geht überhaupt nicht es gibt noch recht
stadt hier dürft euch hier nicht fest
ihr dürft autofahrer nicht dem argument
schlager gegen jede form in dem fall gab
es ein bisschen gab es hier das ein oder
andere verständnisproblem ärger von ist
natürlich nicht in der nähe der afg das
haben sie auch ganz klar noch mal zurück
gehen wir sicher auch demonstriert wenn
sie zu gelesene zeitung nur dass uns
einfach nochmal glaube ich für jeden
zuschauer klar zu stellen falls ist da
zu missverständnissen gekommen ist aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist das thema klima
eines was uns hier am tisch natürlich
umtreibt was viele zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer umtreibt was auch sie umtreibt
und treibt auch nicht aber sie haben es
am anfang gesagt es gibt natürlich
maßnahmen die vielleicht trotz allem und
trotz der intention darauf vielleicht
nicht einzahlen deswegen ich bin zurzeit
kein besonders großer fan des neuen euro
tickets und zwar weil ich denke dass es
einfach seine ja im prinzip die ziele
die sie erreichen soll verfehlt wird es
zum einen natürlich vielleicht auf
steigende verbraucherpreise
anzugehen und da eben entlastung zu
schaffen für die bürgerinnen und bürger
und zum anderen eben so zu sagen
irgendwie so eine bewegung von der
straße weg hinauf die schiene und auf
den öffentlichen nahverkehr zu
initiieren und meines erachtens sind das
ist das aber ein sehr kurzfristig
gedacht ja eigentlich dies kann maßnahme
die uns nirgendwohin bringen wird und
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir das in
deutschland visionärer langfristiger
angehen könnten und vor allem auch
europäischen der frage klimawandel
weiter gehen würde was sagen sie denn
vor konkret also mit euro ticket für
immer oder genau
also ich glaube zum einen was meines
erachtens verpasst wurde europaweit aber
auch in deutschland zum zum anfang als
jetzt die energiepreise gestiegen sind
und da sind wir wieder beim thema auch
bürgerbewegungen was kann ich denn tun
wenn jetzt also zunächst mal wenn die
energiepreise steigen zeigt das ja eine
knappheit im markt das heißt
signalwirkung okay was kann ich denn
jetzt tun um meinen energiekonsum so zu
reduzieren dass im prinzip auf meine
kosten sinken und ich glaube dadurch
dass wir als bürgerinnen und bürger dazu
nicht aufgeklärt wurden was es für
einfache maßnahmen eben einfach auch
gibt
ja wurde da im prinzip ein ganz
wichtiges instrument verfehlt ich glaube
zum anderen kann man natürlich so etwas
nutzen wie
reduzierte preise aber dann vielleicht
für gruppen wie studenten wie rentner
menschen die es wirklich brauchen hat
hier als und jemand das nur ein euro
ticket sich eigentlich was ist kann mir
jemand erklären bitte ausweis leben das
man dann langfristig sein oder sein auto
verkauft wird nur weil man jetzt
39 euro pro monat für öffentliche kassen
zur
bundesweiten
mit dem regionalverkehr fahren von hier
nach sylt und sich
noch mal ganz kurz zwar noch
einmal ganz kurz es gibt ein
entlastungspaket 1 der bundesregierung
leistungspaket 2 der bundesregierung es
geht um das thema energie preise teuer
schock und darum bürgerinnen und bürger
zu entlasten da hat man sich unter
anderem ausgedacht als ampelkoalition
das ist für drei monate lang ein euro
ticket geben sie einen fahrschein für
neun euro im juni kostet euro im juli
kostet neun euro und im august noch mal
neun euro und dann können sie bundesweit
nicht in denen ics und ics fahren aber
sonst können sie bundesweit im
regionalexpress könne jemand auch immer
wieder mehr auf die energie muss ja auch
wieder zurückgehen habe die fahrzeuge
sondern menschen aus dem auto von der
strasse
haben sie es schon ja ich habe eine
umweltkarte also im bvg ticket und es
wird automatisch umgewandelt auf diesen
neuen euro aber das problem ist doch
dass der flug nach mallorca immer noch
viel zu billig ist und es heißt es
funktioniert über den preis am ende wir
unser verhalten verändert der markt in
einer marktwirtschaft aber die machen
sie witze auf kosten der natur auf
kosten zukünftiger dass ich meine im
postkommunistischen staaten anbieter
direkt die sind ja da hat man keine
moschee haben sie in den letzten 150
jahren hier in europa mehr treibhausgase
ausgestoßen als china dafür ihr leben
bei uns die menschen aber auch längeren
85 jahre alt hh mit allerdings letzten
saison anzuknüpfen also was ich mir da
auch sehr viel sinnvoller vorstellen
würde also dieses entlastungspaket soll
zwar kommen über 2,5 milliarden euro
kosten 50 euro ticket dieser ich drei
missed gesamte figur soll ja nur diese
drei monate euro
das bedeutet also dass können wir glaube
ich sehr viel besser
infrastrukturmaßnahmen in e mobilität
auch irgendwie weiter
investieren wir könnten zum beispiel
europäisch auch wirklich mal eine
effektive co2 besteuerung angehen und
soundso abgesehen die chinesen zur kunst
werden am ende müssen wir auch das noch
ein euro ticket bezahlen wir alle selbst
natürlich denn am ende muss der
steuerzahler bezahlt aber die frage die
man sich ja auch stellen kann beim
ganzen thema und wir diskutieren über
klimaschutz und wir diskutieren ist ein
bisschen mit augenzwinkern aber sonst ja
eine sehr wie ernst es ist klimaschutz
überhaupt dürfen wir gar nicht mehr
leben also herr gab man möchte ja unsere
code essen auch mal schnitzel brutzeln
also ist klimaschutz jetzt die
abschaffung eines lebensgefühls und auch
des spaßes am leben als laut sein der
saison größere liebe noch zu einem
selbst zu seinem körper zu den
mitmenschen zu den tieren und zu den
anderen lebewesen mit denen wir hier
diesen planeten auf ein wenig allein es
gibt millionen später mit dem wir uns
diesen planeten teilen im moment haben
wir in den letzten 50 jahren als
menschheit mehr zerstört auf als alle
anderen generationen vor uns und es geht
so nicht weiter schön dass sie ihre
rezepte niemals umsetzen werden können
weil ich hätte doch jeder einzelnen sind
auch in berlin mainz eintreten der
gesellschaft funktioniert sehr viel
komplizierter ihnen möchte ich mal eins
sagen wir haben heute ein ganz 3 wir
haben als journalistin in der
öffentlichkeit stehende person ist sehr
leicht zu diskutieren und die brücke
über die bunte karte ziehen ich finde
dass neun euro ticket eine wichtige
lösung zu einem zeitpunkt wo der
bevölkerung der frust so an wegen der
benzinpreise und den täglichen preis
hypes auch in der bild zeitung dass die
vorkehrungen treffen müssen dass da
nichts zum beispiel nach rechtsaußen
sozusagen rattenfänger abschwimmen und
auch nach links außen die gibt es
nämlich auch mit verlaub die ehefrau und
das ist aus meiner sicht eine wichtige
maßnahme jetzt vor der sommerzeit ja das
sind doch keine idioten um herr scholz
wir werden also prima nicht herr
minister an dem dann daten jetzt haben
wir mehrere bundesländer dazu ist alles
mist ja es geht doch darum ich möchte
daher vielleicht an der stelle sagen
dass ich mich sehr bewusst dafür
entschieden habe letztes jahr im
bundestagswahlkampf zu kandidieren um
nämlich genau konstruktive
lösungsvorschläge zu machen ich glaube
dass unser bundeswirtschaftsminister zur
zeit unglaublich pragmatisch und
lösungshilfen habig
lösungsorientiert
direkt nach auswegen noch während
unserer energieversorgung
gesucht ich hoffe dass jahr bei der
europäische ansatz nicht verloren geht
indem wir als deutschland voran
schreiten ja ich hoffe dass wir europa
mitnehmen aber es ich darf noch trotzdem
eine maßnahme kritisieren ja wie ich
nicht auf
14 ende geht es nicht dafür dass die
lebensmittel oder 9 euro zug fahren oder
so weiter dass es billiger wird soll das
problem ist dass fliegen und tierischen
a und den viel größeren ökologischen
fußabdruck viel teurer serien bei
unseren naro riss in deutschland weniger
als in fast allen europäischen ländern
und deswegen gehen wir auch so
verschwenderisch mit lebensmitteln unter
anderem um weil wir es uns leisten
können jedes jahr dutzende textilien zu
kaufen und wegzuschmeißen weil sie so
billig sind wer würde die kleider und
auch die lebensmittel teurer sein würden
wir achtsamer damit umgehen was in das
handy über den preis was ist denn für
sie ein angemessener preis für einen
flug nach mallorca beispielsweise gerne
sagt also ich denke mal der realistische
preis wenn man den ökologischen schaden
mit einberechnet werden müsste fünf bis
zehnmal teurer sein als weißen schicht
hat ja heute was ich war schon ein kleid
mit schlichtem 3000 leuten die bei 100
euro ach so haben so günstig viel zu
grund von der eine ökobilanz von einem
ticket ja wie viel verbrauchen und du
hast gerade darüber gesprochen wir
brauchen europäische co2 zertifikate die
aber auch im richtigen vernünftigen
preis was mich stutzig macht bei der
frage wie man das auto einher nehme man
den ökologischen abdruck eines e-autos
und sage mal da ist jetzt atomstrom drin
und da ist windstrom drin also gar kein
co2 ausstoßen ja keine kohle und kein
gast so und jetzt habe ich das in berlin
hierher gab man weiß das natürlich auch
stellen wir fest es gibt erste kitze die
wollen komplett autofrei sein wir bauen
die stadt quasi zurück und ist
mittlerweile völlig wurst ob das auto
diesel in einem dieselmotor fährt ob es
ein benziner ist oder ob es ein e auto
ist was passiert ist es gibt einen
feldzug gegen das auto mal eindruck ist
auch es wird immer aktivistischen
feldzug gegen das flugzeug geben es ist
das völlig wurst ob das mit grünem strom
fliegt das flugzeug oder mit solar wir
sehen es beim auto was passiert es
spielt keine rolle was werden parkplätze
reduziert nicht für e autos für sich
aufgebauten sie wenn insgesamt reduziert
man will das auto nicht mehr das ist
offenbar in einer gewissen
gesellschaftlichen gruppe nicht mehr en
vogue selbst wenn der sauber fährt und
beim flugzeug sage ihnen voraus wird das
gleiche auch dass sie also erst mal ganz
kurz ein auto ist nur weil das nur aus
elektro energie funktioniert ist es
nicht sauber sondern damit es
hergestellt wurden hatte erst mal so
viel strom verbraucht und das erste
erstmal zehn jahre benutzen muss damit
man überhaupt sagen kann jetzt kommen
wir langsam als ein break geht man also
quasi eine positive ökobilanz vorher
habe ich einfach nur noch mehr
treibhausgasen im luft gebraucht noch
mehr ressourcen verbraucht was wir
brauchen ist viel weniger autos also
wollen wir
und ich glaube es ist eine neue
fahrzeuge
anschaffen weil ein fahrzeug
normalerweise zu 95 prozent seien es
weiter um steht und wir müssen
effektives system haben um unsere
ressourcen die wir haben gemeinsam mehr
zu nutzen und wir können nicht jeder 102
autos haben ob das nur ein e auto ist
oder ein anderes das geht ökobilanz
technisch mit 8 milliarden also need is
nich es gibt keine autos mehr irgendwann
wie gehen wir
mit den zügen die züge müssen ja auch
immer hergestellt werden auch die
verbrauchen natürlich erstmal deswegen
sage ich ja es sollte nicht darum gehen
dass wir sagen alles soll jetzt gar
nichts mehr kosten sonst geht darum dass
wir den öko be die ökobilanz von den
einzelnen produkten in dem preis
realisieren wenn man gastwirt ist wenn
man's spitzenkoch ist dass er das war
dass wir nicht ruhen welche metern
hausherr die mir vorstellen dass also
die autoindustrie am jahresende noch
zehn prozent für den produziert was sie
bisher produziert haben dann stehen
x1000 100.000 auf der straße für 2008
weist als wert auf der straße und ich
stelle auch über die frage aber ich bin
halt nur koch das elektroauto also
irgendwo muss das zeug auch passiert
wenn die energie und ich komme zurück zu
handys und laptops und ähnlichen dingen
ich komme auch zurück zu aufwendigen
herten und sofort also dass wir könnten
auch ganz schnell in der steinzeit laden
wenn wir wollen und dann geben wir dem
club nürnberg alle gleichzeitig sagen
sie nicht mehr auffällt ist dass das bdr
zu ihrer schicht die burschen haben wir
seit unserer genauso gehabt überhaupt
gar nicht dabei um vielleicht irgendwie
das noch mal auf eine andere ebene zu
heben ich stelle mir die frage in
welcher gesellschaft wollen wir leben
und dann welche wirtschaft brauchen wir
uns in dieser gesellschaft zu gelangen
weil die wirtschaft ist kein selbstzweck
sondern sie es eben darum und als
gesellschaft
prima durch die jahrzehnte getragen
prima ihre generation hat ein thema das
immer noch ich bin eben bruder sterbe
gesorgt welches kommentieren dass wir
leider sehr lange nicht wussten was für
einen schaden fossile brennstoffe und
eben co2 ausstoß anrichten können und da
wir eine verantwortung haben also für
die nächsten generationen und auch
diesen planeten allgemeinen gegenüber
geht es doch eigentlich es geht doch gar
nicht darum schön weit weg was sie sagen
nein das ist überhaupt nicht weit weg
dass es sogar sehr nah dran das ist es
nämlich jetzt schon realität auf die
sensible zeit produzieren müssen panzer
bei rheinmetall und krauss maffei
sie sind da ja auch ein leidenschaft der
diskutant und sie einladen sich vorher
telefonisch sei sie sagen ja auch völlig
zu recht dass das wirtschaftssystem was
wir haben das beste ist um dieses
problem in den griff bekommen wir dürfen
ja einst auch nicht vergessen verstärkt
die co2 der co2 ausstoß im vergleich zu
1990 ist ja bisher so reduziert worden
wie eigentlich die zielvorgabe war und
40 prozent darunter das wäre in der ddr
und im sozialismus nicht möglich gewesen
das hat das kapitalistische system hin
richtig die soziale marktwirtschaft oder
beziehungsweise marktwirtschaft mit
glücklicherweise einen starken sozialen
komponente in deutschland und ich glaube
wir schaffen das auch nur mit einer
marktwirtschaft in die klimaneutralität
aber wir müssen uns eben die frage
stellen was für einen preis sollte denn
klima lassen sie uns doch mal ehrlich
sein dass wir uns den sozialstaat
leisten
können und jetzt haben die armen von
kalkutta und von afrika die für einen
dollar am tag arbeiten damit wir hier
die löhne zahlen können man muss doch
mal irgendwie eben kurz klar werden wie
das zusammenhängen aber ist es sich so
dass die regierung den bildungsauftrag
hat sowohl eine für eine gesunde energie
zu sorgen als auch für eine gesunde
ernährung zu sorgen und damit dann müsse
natürlich regel geschaffen werden neu
geschaffen werden keine frage die touren
auch ein bisschen weh aber wir dürfen
nicht immer nur in weiß und schwarz
denken ja und wenn wir das auto wie sie
eben gesagt haben einfach in
innenstädten abschaffen
ich bin nicht der meinung dass er der
letzte schluss sein wird stehen wir
brauchen doch keine haben gesagt hatte
haushalt ja dass man auch sagen bei
allen dingen einer freien gesellschaft
möchte ich leben ja freien ohne
bevormundung aber auch dass das schön
auch dass wir haben wir natürlich doch
mit zwei jobs hat auch ohne löcher waren
gezielt handeln ist ein mal gucken dass
wir also wer auf dem lande lebt zwar
autos hat er 22 jobs hat der braucht
möglicherweise etwa autos das ist anders
auch nicht hin zu bekommen weil die
busse auch nicht richtig fahren zu
wollen 5 milliarden auch anders
verwenden nämlich in struktur
investitionen auch auf dem land und ich
bin in der nähe von frankfurt am main
aufgewachsen auch ich hätte nicht ohne
auto fast gar nicht fortbewegen können
weil in meinem ort ungefähr dreimal am
tag ein bus vorbei kam
also die realität sind nun mal so aus
als ob es ist irgendwie gute lösungen
finden aber ich glaube auch dass uns
nichts bringt einfach nur zu sagen na
die wirtschaft so wie sie ist es doch
gut so und wir bleiben jetzt einfach
dabei weil hiermit alle bist du weil
weil sich leider die rahmenbedingungen
verändert haben und das müssen wir
einfach verschluss frau sternberg
vorstellen dass das schlusswort wir
müssten das weiter diskutieren aber die
zeit ist so in der graf frontfrau
sternberg herr lohse und filmer ganz
ganz herzlichen dank für diese wirklich
spannende runde das war ganz toll meine
damen und herren ich hoffe sie hatten
auch ganz ganz viel spaß ich wünsche
einen wunderschönen feiertag morgen
machen sie es gut wie sollen sie nächste
woche wieder verlangt auf wiedersehen